a lot of things you just said i really
uh
like got turned on by like addicted to
ketamine
[ __ ] love ketamine i can't have it i
can't have it anymore either
but didn't bring out the god
yeah i i wasn't very cool on it but i
[ __ ] thought i was but it felt cool
yeah that's
but so that's one of the that's one of
the weird things about ketamine is it
gives you this bizarre
like narcissism like it may really like
[ __ ] with your like ability to
oh dude what it is is uh
like pharmaceutical pcp
it falls in the class of drug known as
dissociative
yeah and uh pcp is a much like dirtier
street version but they they have a lot
in common
hold on writing down need to try peace
oh my god i did i was about equally uh
uh
out there on both i'm curious about it
like what what's it like
what's what are your guys's like worst k
experiences or like
best but when you're in a k hall how
long does it last what are you thinking
are you thinking you're going to die are
you tripping or are you loving it
i think that the the the the general big
picture answer is that
it that it's a real moving target man
it's
like a various experiences like are
the various you know i mean like i i can
but you first man
and i'll take it away uh let's not
go for best or worse experience but just
notable
um well you know what i'm gonna look it
up real quick and see if i can find it
the guy who invented float tanks
was really into ketamine and he actually
created a
yeah here it is it's so funny he did
this but he created a dosage
chart where he actually
mapped the experiences out based on
milligram dosages if you look it up just
john lily ketamine chart
so he's got here now i don't know
because i was like
insulating i have no idea like what the
what the injection
what this means compared to like
snorting it but at 30 milligrams you've
got
something he's calling internal reality
75 milligrams which he which he
calls i 75 milligrams a day
extraterrestrial reality 150 milligrams
we the network of creation and then
300 milligrams unknown
can you overdose on ketamine oh my god
i'm so excited to talk to you duncan
i mean honestly i had like i i'm so
excited on so many levels
and um like like what you just described
there
really i think reinforces my personal
experiential
theory that there's something absolutely
spiritual in in drugs and and
particularly even in ketamine
but oh god ketamine is like um one of my
friends
who writes all these books on the occult
calls it occult cocaine
it's a it's such a occult substance it's
a
you know something about the
disassociative effect
uh it opens up i mean you can call it
whatever you want but i think it's a i
think
i think you you go into alternate
universes sure
here's what i think is that that like we
are
sort of relegated to this physical
reality
or sorry physical illusion in this third
dimensional
sort of compartment and i believe that
when we ingest you know certain
chemicals
and a variety of chemicals that what we
do is we essentially
erode the barriers in between said
apartments and kind of open ourselves up
to
entities from other dimensions it's a
dangerous thing to do with drugs
because with with drugs like when you
those those barriers that we are eroding
are essentially
protective in a number of ways and by
eroding the barriers we open ourselves
up to sort of uh all
you know all things you know other
dimensional and that
comes with a lot of like very low
frequency
and low frequency i would categorize as
deep demonic you know like demons and
high frequency being like sort of angels
so when i was you know at the end of my
run with drugs and alcohol
i was like [ __ ] routinely and i was
so excited about it because i felt privy
to what was going on
like in other dimensions with spiritual
beings
so i just couldn't keep piling in enough
drugs to keep it happening like
the the the hallucinations that i was
having
both visual like hearing the voices you
know
uh uh audio uh like tactile where you
actually
feel it you know and i ha i categorized
all of the
experiences with these beings as demons
and
angels and then the third category which
i now think of as demons
trickster spirits were they they were
just straight trying to [ __ ]
entertain me and boy did they
because like i was like sitting in a
chair i remember i was like snorting
cocaine i was
inhaling nitrous oxide i had all pills
weed everything and i just thought to
myself
as i went to go do this line of cocaine
i just thought there's no longevity in
this like i'm straight
killing myself right now yeah and then i
had the thought
[ __ ] it i don't care like i don't care
if i die i had that thought i don't care
if i die
lean over to do this line of cocaine and
the swiveling
office chair that i was in as i leaned
over
it physically spun around like a big
strong dude grabbed it and
like with the force of like a mechanical
bull and
now i know intellectually for a fact
that i did not actually spin if there
was a surveillance camera in my
apartment
nothing would have happened but i'm
telling you i had that experience a very
tactile experience
and there was another time sitting in
that same exact chair the whole [ __ ]
chair
just straight erupted into flames and
like
every time i had one of these
experiences i'm like okay this is
[ __ ] cool
you know this is going on let me double
check is it yeah i just
double checked and it's still going on
the flames all engulfing me
it's not hot i'm perfectly comfortable
but it's just really [ __ ] cool that i
happen to be
in a chair engulfed in flames like i had
this skateboard
uh screwed to the wall uh so it was uh
you know vertical right and i had a
globe
screwed to the skateboard so the globe
was protruding over the doorway to the
apartment
you know like uh horizontally and
i like like the [ __ ] liquid
terminator i watched that globe
like my own face like pushed through it
you know like like it was the liquid
term yeah you could see my face push
through it
and then [ __ ] it just started [ __ ]
headbanging
and i'm like [ __ ] right on you know
these curtains do it just on their own
open and close and open and close
where that wasn't possible there were
lights that were never [ __ ] there
that was just flashing like it just
turned into a [ __ ] rave
all this stuff was going on and and and
i was like this is the coolest [ __ ]
thing i just have to keep doing more and
more drugs
yeah can i just tell you how [ __ ] up
my new tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated
there's legal waivers all over the venue
because i'm actually worried about
getting sued
and i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats